all right let's go back to the phones
let's go to mary in washington mary how
are you
i'm doing okay thank you for taking my
call you bet thanks for calling in how
can i help
well okay so uh my husband and i
are at it in disagreement about um
paying for college for our youngest
child okay okay
um we finally got past um
well we're on the ramsay step so baby
step two paying off a mountain of debt
and now we've got baby steps three and
four done
so saving for retirement have uh
congratulations
right way to go mary okay uh it's been
a long long haul okay so our youngest
daughter is in
college and my husband is pretty
resistant to helping her with college
tuition and i am fully on board with
helping her
now he says he doesn't like seeing the
money get spent
i don't want her getting trapped in debt
like we have been okay
um we weren't able to help our first two
kids as much because we were trapped in
debt
um the my daughter is beginning her
junior year studying mechanical
engineering
she has pretty decent portion paid by an
academic scholarship
okay and she's also holding down a job
she maintains a 3.5 gpa or above she's
in the honors college
honors program on the dean's list and
such
she does do some typical college stuff
so her dad
listens to her stories about college
life as if he's the cool dad
and then says to me he doesn't want to
fund that kind of college life
so oh yeah i disagree with his tactics
and
and i don't know how to resolve this
problem because he's you know we have
this giant mountain of debt
finally have some money that we get to
spend and
that's what i want to spend money on and
the mountain of debt okay so i've let go
of the anger and resentment
that was going on with where the debt
came from and how it was accumulated and
stuff
that was going to be my question is is
the debt him related
yeah i mean he he was
he didn't do it on purpose but he got
kind of caught up it was business debt
okay and he got sucked into the hole
that a lot of people are like well you
finance everything
and i found out about it because i was
working my own job
and raising kids and stuff and then i
you know looked over his stuff and said
what what is happening here
and uh so got him on track
but it took seven years to pay off that
much debt wow okay so
debt for a long time and now
we have no debt and we get to keep our
income
and move ahead but i want to help this
kid with college i didn't get to help
the other two with college well our
second kid we helped a little bit
because we were getting closer to the
end of the debt but
he's resistant to this now i should tell
you also
he's from a family that higher education
is not important to them
sure i mean when he was graduating from
high school you know he still had the
cap and gown on and his parents were
like
are you giving back the keys are we
having the locks changed
you know right right so he's not from a
family that
really values higher education i mean
they admire it but they don't
help their kids sure so let me hop in
here i
the question about paying for college is
a symptom of a deeper
rooted issue here issue number one is
you haven't let go you being you mary
you haven't let go of that seven year
journey you all took
there is still a part of you that has
resentment
has hurt has frustration has anger has
whatever word you want to put there
has a rage that you spent seven years
digging out of a hole that you didn't
that you didn't dig and until you
let that go and until my guess is your
husband
either has some sort of um
guilt that he carries around that he dug
a hole like that whether it was on
purpose or stupid
or he's annoyed that you're frustrated
whatever that is
right but here's here's here's why
you've gotta put that stuff
down because you two can't fully dream
together on what tomorrow's gonna look
like if you're still carrying bricks
from the past
and what you're telling me about your
daughter there's gonna be guilt from
your husband that he didn't help the
first two
or didn't help the first one and only
help the second one a little bit and so
we probably should help the third one
or the third one gets to go out and
party and drink beer and that means
by default i'm not finding that kind of
life because i got to work hard and i
and you know i get that that attitude i
hear i hear that often as well
so there's both you're going to have
guilt that you didn't help so now you
got a chance to we could
could be helping both those of the
guilts both of these should we or
shouldn't be
that's simply a values question and you
can't have values conversations
if you're still hanging on to the past
and so
my deepest deepest recommendation for
you
is to spend some time with yourself
spend some time with
a pastor or counselor or
you may have already done this mary you
may have already done this hard work but
go spend some time with your husband and
y'all go get breakfast somewhere
my friend anthony o'neil he always says
go to a nice dinner i like doing a nice
breakfast because everybody's fresher
and a little bit smarter in the morning
and a little bit more
bright-eyed and coffee helps a little
bit but go have a breakfast
off-site go somewhere where y'all can
get out and if you're
in washington washington still may be
closed down so go hiking together go
somewhere
and i want you to write him a letter
that goes through what the last seven
years what the 10 years were
paying for this debt and you apologize
for holding this on for so long
and i want you to look in the eye and
say i'm letting this go i forgive you i
forgive us i'm proud of the journey
here we are moving forward and then
number two
is i want you to say
i want to have a values conversation
about what the back half of our life is
going to be
or the last 25 of our life is going to
be
how are we going to actually spend this
money because for your husband it may
feel so
good that he finally has from the
account and any of it leaving
hurts right because he just doesn't want
to go back to that place
and for you finally having something to
count god almighty dude we just want to
help out people we're going to and we
want to help by we're going to start
helping
by looking at our own daughter and
helping her out she's doing great she's
kicking butt
she's going to go be a successful member
of a family of a community
she's making us proud and i'm going to
support that that starts with a values
conversation
my friend chris hogan calls it planning
in hd
i like to say plan it with a picture i
want you to
draw a picture of what thanksgiving is
going to look like in five years and
work back
draw a picture about christmas morning
in five years who's around the tree what
gifts
are you handing to people and work
backwards from that
when you what's a picture of your
daughter crossing the graduation
stage does she have a diploma in one
hand and student loan dead in the other
does she have a diploma in one hand and
she is waving to you guys
up in the stands hopefully we're not
still doing virtual graduations then
but she's waving to you with a debt-free
hand what does that picture look like
and when you paint in pictures with
partners
it's just so much easier to see it and
you feel it
it's not this abstract thing not this i
don't want my kit
it becomes look hon i want my daughter
to walk across that stage
free i want her to be free of this
nonsense
and right now we can help but that comes
first with you letting go too
so mary thank you so so much for that
call
anybody who's struggling to get on the
same page with your partner you've got
to first look in the mirror
about anything what kind of car we
should have should we get on the dave
ramsey financial plan
should we have another kid should we
help pay for college
should our kids be wearing those clothes
out in the community my kids got a crazy
mohawk right now
and my wife was like do we have to let
him go out into the neighborhood looking
like that
right those are all values conversations
and you can't have values conversations
when you're frustrated you can't have
them when you're angry and you
especially can't have
values conversations when you're hanging
on to things that have happened in the
past
so do the hard work if you can do it by
yourself great if you can do it in
community great if you need a
professional grade to
set down your bricks set down the crap
you're carrying about other people
get off site get out of the emotion get
out of the crazy
and then have values conversations that
are looking to the future
not to the past and those often start
those often start with an apology right
i'm sorry for what i've held onto